INTERESTING, THANKS, MIKE.
APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME NOW, ARIZONA
CONGRESSMAN'S BIGS, HOW ARE YOU
CONGRESSMAN?
YOU ALSO RECENTLY SAT DOWN WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON SATURDAY TO
TALK ABOUT THIS VERY ISSUE.
WHAT IS IT GOING TO TAKE TO
BREAK THE STALEMATE?
>> WHAT IT IS GOING TO TAKE IS
CHUCK SCHUMER IS GOING TO HAVE
TO BITE THE BULLET AND FOND OF
THE WALL.
THEY NEED TO PAY $5 BILLION,
WHICH IS A SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTION
FROM A $25 BILLION THAT IT WILL
TAKE TO ACTUALLY BUILD THE WALL.
THEY NEED TO MOVE.
IT IS ALL IN CHUCK SCHUMER'S
COURT RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS NOTHING ON THE
PRESIDENT'S DESK, VETO OR SIGN,
IS A SHUTDOWN RIGHT NOW.
>> Lisa: WHAT INCENTIVE DO
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND NEGOTIATE OR GIVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANY FUNDING,
NANCY PELOSI IS GOING TO TAKE
OVER, LIKELY, AS SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE JUST NEXT WEEK.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
WHAT INCENTIVE DO THEY HAVE TO
PLAY BALL HERE?
>> WHAT IS GOING TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM ARE TWO THINGS, THEY LOVE
THIS COUNTRY AND RECOGNIZE THE
BORDER IS INSECURE RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A WALL.
THAT IS ONE THING.
THE OTHER THING I THINK WE'LL DO
IT, IS IF THEY REALIZE THAT
THEIR BASE, A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF BUREAUCRATS, AND THEY AREN'T
GETTING PAID IN A SHUTDOWN.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET PRESSURE
FROM THEIR BASE TO COME TO THE
TABLE.
THE REALITY IS THERE THE ONES
LEFT CHOSEN TO SHUT THIS DOWN,
ACTUALLY, NOT THE PRESIDENT.
>> Lisa: CONGRESSMAN, ISN'T
THIS A LOT ABOUT POLITICS?
THE WAY I SEE IT, A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER, THEY
VOTED FOR FENCING ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, THEREFORE A
PHYSICAL STRUCTURE ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
ISN'T THIS JUST ABOUT DENYING
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT HE -- IN
THE CAMPAIGN PROMISE HE MADE?
>> BELIEVE IT OR NOT, I HAVE
FRIENDS IN CONGRESS WHO ARE
DEMOCRATS, AND I ASKED THEM,
WHAT IS THE DEAL HERE?
WHAT IS GOING ON?
ONCE YOU GIVE US ANYTHING FOR A
BORDER WALL, I LIVE IN A BORDER
STATE, WE ARE CONCERNED.
THEY SAID, I DON'T LIKE THE
RHETORIC THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
USES, THE OTHER ONE SAID, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO GIVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP A VICTORY.
WHAT I'M TELLING YOU IS, IT IS
POLITICS, LISA.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM.
THEY DON'T WANT PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO HAVE A VICTORY.
IN SO DOING, THEY ARE PREVENTING
THIS COUNTRY FROM HAVING SAFETY.
JUST TODAY EVEN, MORE PEOPLE
FROM THE BORDER TELLING ME,
"ANDY, THEY ARE CROSSING OUR
PROPERTY, WE HAVE TO HAVE A
BORDER WALL."
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
NOT POLITICS, WE NEED GOOD
POLICY, WHICH INCLUDES A BORDER
WALL.
>> Lisa: SPEAKING OF THE
POLICY ASPECT, EVEN BEYOND THE
WALL, THE BIG CRISIS FACED RIGHT
NOW ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
WE HAVE SEEN A MASSIVE INFLUX OF
PEOPLE SEEKING ASYLUM FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA.
CAN YOU TELL THE VIEWERS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT IS GOING
ON WITH ASYLUM-SEEKERS, AND WHY
WE ARE SEEING THIS INFLUX OF
CENTRAL AMERICANS DOING JUST
THAT?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING, AND
ASYLUM-SEEKERS COMES ACROSS THE
BORDER, WE DO AN IMMEDIATE
EVALUATION, AND THEY END UP
STAYING -- WE CAN'T KEEP THEM
LONGER THAN 20 DAYS, SO WE CAN'T
PROCESS THEM BECAUSE THE INFLUX
IS SO GREAT.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS.
FOR INSTANCE, IN THE PHOENIX
METRO AREA, THERE HAVE BEEN
ALMOST 4,000 OF THEM RELEASED
SINCE OCTOBER UNTIL ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AGO, THE TOTAL FROM TWO
WEEKS AGO.
COMING HERE SEEKING ASYLUM, THEY
ARE RELEASED INTO THE INTERIOR.
WE PAY FOR THEM TO GO WHEREVER
THEY WANT TO GO BECAUSE WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO HOLD THEM.
THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING, CATCH
AND RELEASE, AND WE ARE GIVING
THEM A NOTICE, PLEASE COME BACK,
WE SAY, FOR YOUR COURT HEARING
TO PROVE YOU REALLY ARE SOMEONE
WHO QUALIFIES.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, ALMOST 90% OF
THEM DON'T EVEN QUALIFY FOR
ASYLUM, YET THEY ARE ALREADY
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
MOST NEVER GO BACK FOR THE
HEARING.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
THE ASYLUM POLICY TODAY.
>> Lisa: SOMETHING NOT
REPORTED AS MUCH, THE DEAL WITH
MEXICO, KEEPING ASYLUM-SEEKERS
IN MEXICO WHILE THEY ARE WAITING
FOR THEIR IMMIGRATION CASES.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, 90 PERCENT
DON'T ACTUALLY GET GRANTED
ASYLUM IN IMMIGRATION COURT.
THE PROBLEM IS A LOT OF THEM GO
MISSING BETWEEN THAT TIME AND
WHEN THEIR CASES COME UP.
WHY IS THIS SO IMPORTANT?
>> IF YOU CAN KEEP THEM IN
MEXICO, WHICH, BY THE WAY, HAS
OFFERED ASYLUM.
LIKE THE CARAVAN, THEY OFFER
THEM ASYLUM.
IF YOU KEEP THEM THERE, IT GIVES
US TIME TO PROCESS THEM BEFORE
THEY GET RELEASED INTO THE
INTERIOR.
THEY ARE EFFECTIVELY LOSS UNTIL
THEY COMMIT A CRIME WHERE WE CAN
TRACK THEM DOWN AND I.C.E. CAN
GET HOLD OF THEM.
A CENTURY CITY, NOT GOING TO
COOPERATE WITH I.C.E.
WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF OBSTACLES
THAT KEEP US FROM ACTUALLY
CONTROLLING THE FOLKS THAT ARE
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS WHY THE MEXICO,
BASICALLY KEEPING THEM THERE
UNTIL THEY ARE READY TO COME IN,
QUALIFY TO COME IN, IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THERE'S GOING TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, THAT WE CAN'T
TRACK, WE CAN'T VENT, WE DON'T
KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
>> Lisa: IS CONGRESS DOING
ANYTHING TO ADDRESS THE ASYLUM
ISSUES WE ARE SEEING?
>> WE HAVE BASICALLY PUT
TOGETHER A SERIES OF BILLS, THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS HAS PUT TOGETHER
SOME IDEAS AND SOME BILLS TO TRY
TO GET THIS GOING, BUT THE FIRST
THING THAT HAS TO HAPPEN,
REALLY, IS THE BORDER WALL.
WHEN I TALKED TO MY BORDER
PATROL AGENTS, THEY SAY ANDY, WE
NEED THE BORDER PATROL, I.C.E.,
WE NEED THE BORDER WALL FIRST.
ONCE WE HAVE THE BORDER WALL, IT
WILL PUT PEOPLE INTO A CHANNEL
SO THEY ARE COMING TO PORTS OF
ENTRY, WE CAN CONTROL IT BETTER.
THEN WE CAN START DEALING WITH
INTERIOR PROBLEMS LIKE ASYLUM.
>> Lisa: REAL QUICK, HOW LONG
DO YOU THINK THE SHUTDOWN WILL
LAST?
>> WELL, SINCE THE PRESIDENT IS
HOLDING FIRM AND THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE SAID THEY ARE NOT WILLING
TO BUDGE ON THIS, I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GO AT LEAST ANOTHER
COUPLE OF WEEKS, ACTUALLY.